uh my homes are tired to play baseball
i'm just focused on getting my 20th ring
lamar
we have to go we're being eliminated by
ryan tannehill
ryan tannehill towards acl three years
ago man we could beat the titans in our
sleep hey man great job out there you're
the future of our league
no trust what happened it's the haunting
of tana hill house
[Music]
oh we're boot to have a fun vacation get
away hey fellow young stars
yeah no to canadian chase claypool wait
did we all wear letterman jackets i
thought
i was a jock in this crew no i'm the
joker ah who's that
they say the ghosts of all the injured
cubies left for dead live there
but some of them find a way back
it's the pet neck manning i created
adam guys so you see god damn it when am
i gonna get the respect i do you really
think these old heads can come back and
haunt us
yo it wasn't me broncos don't play
lights out i'm sorry in advance turns
out i'm good now
oh no it's a trap game
i'll take kfc sauce and i like my extra
crispy tenders boneless
not cool man 100 white meat tenders
available now
sorry i boot your poor american health
care there ryan true lock the door what
about the door go out the door
oh remember the chargers model
things are bad now but the feature looks
okay
hello prepare to be gone baby gone
hey i like this one actually oh of
course there are you get whatever you
want man
don't look in the mirror co-scrutin says
mirrors are for rock stars and
basketball players for some reason
you're the only one here i can beat
i found the red zone eh i'm not like you
guys the cowboys are gonna take me back
yeah but do you want to go back oh i
never thought of it like that oh wait
it's my turn i'm coming for you but
watch out because i'm
super confusing hello minka you
hold on i'm not actually dead i can come
back from this quiet you people still
somewhat respect me here in 2018. you
might want to find a way out of here
he was a victim of gays just like me
so many wasted years whoa we're still
undefeated how weird is that sure was
nice to meet you ghost
wants you to subscribe but jimmy also
wants
a hug just because we be
team monster don't mean we be monster
monster i must eat to survive